- On this episode we
(dial tone) do it again.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 202
of the The #AskGaryVee Show.
I have some new kicks.
Get in here Staphon.
Feeling' pretty
good about these.
Went with the blue
shirt along with it.
India is here.
- Hi.
- And we are very focused
on a 202 call-in show.
We're bringing it right back.
All of you hated on it.
We made some adjustments.
We think we got
something, India.
- Yep.
- Are you ready to
get into the call-in--
- [Both] Show?
- I am although--
- No, no.
We weren't done yet.
- It's been like
outsourced to robots.
You know?
It's the future.
- Oh you got very upset and
what happened in 200, huh?
- No, it's actually
kind of nice.
- Or you just so
busy with the in--
- Yeah, I have so many
meetings the schedule.
It's kind of a relief.
- Alright, let's do
it one more time.
Are you ready for the--
- [Both] Show?
- Very good.
Andy, this is on you.
Are you ready to
take responsibility
if this is glitchy?
They didn't like the cadence.
They didn't like the chop.
We think we got it.
- I'm ready to add
operator to the resume.
- [Gary] Alright, operator.
Let's do it.
Episode 202 of
The #AskGaryVee Show,
Facebook Live you are the
backbone of the
call-in and live episodes.
949-793-7611, call in the show.
And we'll get to the first
caller in one second but if you
are not following me on
Facebook, Staphon, let's do a
nice little edit here.
Let Zak or Andrew
design something here.
Not like your font.
Get something pretty here that
says Facebook.com/Gary,
please and link those links up
on YouTube and Facebook
when we post it.
On Facebook that's kind of
weird but anyway on YouTube.
Make sure you're following
'cause Facebook Live will be
the backbone of me
doing this show.
Oh by the way, I have an idea,
this is ad hoc even though we're
filming it will be in the
show this is not really for the
show, give me one second.
Actually, you know what?
Black-and-white this out.
You don't usually do that,
do that for me right now.
I think we should
do a commercial.
Something screwed up?
- [Andy] Spinning
wheel of death on Aircall.
- Yes.
You're in deep trouble, right?
I love it.
(laughter)
While you crash that out, while
you panic, I'll tell these guys.
Are you dead?
- [DRock] Andy, Force quit.
- [Andy] Yeah. Spinning wheel of death.
Everything I can do
but if I go here--
- [Gary &amp; DRock] So force quit.
- I love it.
- [Andy] I don't think
it's going to fix it.
Right before I was talking to
the guy and he was like I was
talking with the tech team, how
many exactly do you think are
going to be calling in?
I was like a lot.
It's going to be a lot of
calls in a short amount of time.
He's like alright, when's
the day for the show?
10 minutes.
Oh, wow wow wow.
Wow wow.
(laughter)
- Alright, so what's
gonna happen now?
- [Andy] I'm gonna quit.
- I'm going to stall
here while you do this.
India, find a question.
- [Andy] We're going to
go to old-school way.
We have a new number.
- No, we can't do the
old-school way.
I think that thing was
really working well.
- [Andy] It's broken.
We broke it.
- We didn't break it yet.
You give up so easily.
- [Andy] I can't even, I have
to shut down my computer.
- Let me show how you do it.
It's very easy.
You go hmmmm, you
hold it, you hold it.
Good.
What the problem
going to lose stuff?
- [Andy] I mean
cool but then all right.
- But what?
- We can still use the
Google Voice number.
- I don't want to.
I want to use this thing.
- [India] I have questions.
- [Andy] Google Voice works.
- India, you ask a question.
I'm not using Google Voice,
I want to use that thing.
Is that the guy calling?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- I love it, good hustle.
Way to watch.
You keep doing your
thing, we'll do our thing.
- Want to talk about what
you would do if you were
the CEO of Yahoo.
- Yeah, let's talk about it.
- If you woke up and you are
the CEO of Yahoo what would you
revitalize the company?
From Robert.
- I think what I would do is
truthfully a lot of M&amp;A,
mergers and acquisition.
I would go and look at the
Anchors and the Musically's and
the after schools and the
things that are emerging in the
marketplace and realize what I
have is a business model that is
cold or not working as well
and not rolling so that's what I
have an issue in and when I have
an advantage in is that I have
dollars and assets and money
from Alibaba and other places
that I can deploy and so I think
when your core business is not
driving upward mobility
in growth in your company.
The thing you do is you
leverage that asset to try and
build up your future.
And so my answer would be M&amp;A.
I think to Marissa's credit, the
current CEO, and I have a lot of
respect for her and I think
it was a tough gig that
she jumped into.
She went out and did that and
bought Tumblr for a big nut.
And to me in hindsight if she
would have been able to buy
Instagram instead of Facebook
buying it though I'm sure Kevin
wouldn't have sold to Yahoo
that he would have to Facebook.
There was definitely other, I do
believe that when Marissa became
the CEO there was probably a
moment where she could have
bought Snapchat for 1 billion
or two but then the question
becomes when you buy these hot
things on the way up do they
stop becoming those hot things
once they go and get cashed out
and there's not the same energy.
The other thing I would have
thought about is hardware.
I'm very obsessed right now
with the notion of hardware.
I think Facebook should
absolutely, don't worry about
the cost I think that Facebook
should absolutely make a
television for example.
I think Yahoo could
have made a television,
could have made
a Netflix competitor.
I didn't like your
reaction there Andy.
Worry about the cost.
(laughter)
And so the biggest thing
I would say to all of you
to make this a little more
relevant to so many that watch
why don't you focus
on the following.
If you're in a business that
has a situation where it's not
growing as well, you need to
kind of disrupt yourself and try
to make new revenue angles
and try to do different things.
If you stay the course and try
to do incremental things
that grow your business
that becomes a vulnerability.
So if you're in a 3 to 4 your
year funk where your business
is flat, you have to really change
the business not just do what
you're doing a
little bit better.
For example, Wine Library one
thing I've always debated that
if we capped out our growth on
the wine stuff is to really build
out Gourmet Library and become
like a supermarket and sell
cheese and gourmet meats
and things of that nature.
That's a big change than
just doing wine selling
a little bit better.
Doing a little bit better on
email service to adding a couple
more selections or changing
the pricing strategy on the core
business so if I was Yahoo CEO a
year ago and just trying to grow
the business, not taking any of
the Wall Street dynamics into
play which Marissa had to,
I would've done very drastic
things in hardware would
have been on the forefront.
I think phones are too hard.
I think televisions are easier
and so I would have done is made
a Yahoo television
that was unbelievable.
Would have bought a TV producing
company that makes TVs and put
Yahoo at the forefront of
the brand and then build an
over-the-top Netflix like
business and produce original
content that would have driven
into there because Amazon and
Netflix are now making
some of the best television
in the world.
That means anybody can.
Facebook, Snapchat, anybody
can and that's what I'd done.
I probably would've reached out
to this guy named GaryVee and
give him a late night show.
That would've worked.
Andy?
- [Andy] Yo.
- You ready to go?
- Yep.
- [DRock] Same number?
- [Gary] Same number?
- Same number.
- Good.
949-793-7611.
(phone rings) Here we go.
Alright.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
To accept press one.
- Pedro?
- [Pedro] Yes.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk you're
on The #AskGaryVee Show
episode 202. How are you?
- [Pedro] Oh my
god, I'm good now.
You're my man, my Jesus.
What is going on?
- I appreciate it, man.
Pedro, what can I help you with?
Where are you from and
what's your question?
- [Pedro] I am from
Portland, Oregon.
I am the social media
specialist of MotoCorsa Ducati.
My question is
about live streaming.
- Okay.
- [Pedro] As far as preparation
for live streaming if you are
going to do Periscope or
Snapchat how much do you need to
be prepared for that?
- I think that and thanks of the
question it makes a lot of sense
obviously when you're an
entrepreneur or personal brand,
I actually think the
more ghetto the better.
The more real there are so many
other platforms, your Instagram
photos your Facebook posts,
there's a lot of places to
go to polished.
I actually think live
streaming's big upside is
actually just the real and the
raw and the lack of preparation
is really attractive and has
been the reason people loved
reality TV and the reason
they would love Periscope.
Now when you work in a big
company like you and others,
you need to be careful.
Is there something
in the background?
Is there a document on the
desk that people can see?
You got all these things you
have to worry about that big
companies worry about so you
need some level of preparation
but I think that's awareness
to what could happen
versus actually prepping.
You know what I mean?
- [Pedro] Right, yeah, perfect.
Pretty much all of our
good stuff if on-the-fly.
- Always man.
- [Pedro] No preparation.
- Pedro, always.
I'm going to go next call.
I appreciate you
watching, brother.
I love you. Thank you for that.
The bottom line is that people
are always going to be more
attracted to the authentic.
There is an absolute place
for the polished movies, TV.
I think YouTube's an incredible,
look were doing DailyVee
polished because I
believe in the strategy.
In a world where now I believe
YouTube videos are going to be
very easily consumed on
televisions all across America
I think it's a good strategy.
You got a call coming Andy?
How's it going?
- [Andy] I had it
and then right when--
- It's all right.
Here we go.
I think it is super important
to recognize that real and
authentic is just as potentially
important as polished.
I think way too many creators
and videographers and
people that make videos
always overthink that.
They don't understand that the
raw (phone rings) can be just as
good as the glossy.
It's like fashion, India.
Like a great suit is great
a little bit of swag in the
T-shirt is great too.
Let's go to the next one.
That's right.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
To accept--
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on episode 202
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Who's calling and
where you calling from?
Hello?
- [Caller] Hello?
Gary?
- Yes.
- [Alex] Hey, what's up Gary?
This is Alex Schwartz.
How are you doing, man?
- I'm doing super well, Alex.
Where you from?
- [Alex] I'm from San Diego.
- Love it.
Everybody's very lazy in
San Diego. Don't you agree Alex?
- [Alex] Totally agree.
It's a bunch of party
people and pot heads.
Hard to do business here.
- I agree man.
You need to move to New York.
- [Alex] I wish but
it's too cold for me.
I'm originally from Brazil.
(laughter)
- Respect.
Alex, what's your question?
What can I answer for you?
- [Alex] I'm an IT consultant
and I'm kind of struggling on
going to the next level of just
being me, the IT consultant,
to actually creating a
business and a brand.
Unfortunately, I'm
usually known as the IT guy.
- Yep.
- [Alex] The PC Guy, and it
sucks but I don't care because
it's good money.
- Yep.
- [Alex] How do I move from
being the PC guy to actually
having a business,
a name and grow.
- What do you want?
Alex, what you want
the business to be?
What do you want to sell?
- It's IT consulting and IT
support and IT management.
- Got it.
You want your own gig and you
want to build a personal brand
so that clients then come to
you and you can build
employees underneath you.
At first you'll do your own work
and then you'll get other people
and you'll build a firm like I
did with VaynerMedia, right?
- [Alex] Correct.
- You gotta put...
Go ahead.
- [Alex] I'm putting the work
but it just me and my name and
I'm kind of struggling--
- Well that's because--
- [Alex] It's actually
business, not just me.
- Yeah, I get it.
The way you gotta do that
first of all is produce content.
Become bigger of a name.
Put out all your best advice.
Blog on Medium, put out
Instagram tips, do white papers
on Slideshare, do Facebook
Lives, Periscopes, make content,
make content, make content.
Show your expertise, have
inbound business and just like
with VaynerMedia, people want
to hire Gary Vaynerchuk but
Gary Vaynerchuk's
not available.
It's VaynerMedia.
But guess what, Gary Vaynerchuk
was available in 2009, '10, '11
and '12 and then I made enough
money to hire other people and
Gary Vaynerchuk
wasn't available.
Right now, don't stress about
the semantics whether they want
you or your business you don't
have the money or the need to
hire a bunch of people yet.
Create such demand that you take
those dollars and hire people
and then just tell new clients
it's my expertise delivered to
my employees but you don't need
me to physically fix your PC,
got it?
- [Alex] Got it.
Now, real quick question you
always say that Facebook is
doing much better for
ads than Google ads,
do you still believe that?
Do you think I should,
if I were to run
some ads should I go--
- You should do both.
I think Google search is great
for the business you're in.
I do think Facebook is
better for content and branding.
You should do both but my first
start making a lot of content.
I need you blogging on
Medium.com about your thoughts
on PC and your thoughts on IT
and your thoughts on tech in
today's society over and over
and over again content, content,
content video, written form,
audio, Soundcloud, Anchor.
All of it.
It's all about
the content, Alex.
Thank you brother.
Thanks for being on the show.
Let's get onto to
the next call Andy.
I don't know if you
got it figured out yet.
(phone rings)
Oh my God.
(laughter)
I'm getting excited.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
- Kyle.
Kyle, turn down your audio.
How are you?
Oh, we lost him.
We didn't figure out the hack.
Kyle gave up and hung up.
- [Andy] Kyle!
- [Gary] Kyle.
Listen, Kyle is making
your game look bad, Andy.
India, actually I found
a new thing for you.
- [India] Oh really?
- Yeah, good news.
Computers have not
taken over your life yet.
- I'm cool with that too.
- No, I know you are.
But what's really cool is
that we can, in these in-between
moments where funny things
like what's going on with Andy
(upbeat hip hop music)
questions and
things of that nature.
It a whole new
little thing for us.
- A mini show in the show.
- [Both] Cool.
- Yeah. Like it.
Andy what's going on?
Go ahead, India.
(phone rings)
Oh here we go.
Vancouver.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
To accept...
- Hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on episode 202 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Who's this and where you from?
- [Sylvia] Hi Gary.
This is Sylvia I'm from
Vancouver, Canada.
- Hey, how are you?
- [Sylvia] Good.
I have a question for you and
my question is I'm breaking into
the online market.
I have made courses before but
I took some time away and
now it's...
- Darn it, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It was too choppy.
She was breaking it online
courses I could hear it but she
was also breaking up.
And I'm so sorry.
I hate this but I have to
navigate the cadence and the
flow of the show and
it was just too choppy.
Andy can't figure
out the choppiness?
I know we're not doing is the
way, we're not screening calls
and I think we should
continue not to screen calls.
I know a lot of you are like,
screen calls and do this I get
it this is how
we're gonna do it.
(phone rings)
You know?
That's the way it's going to be.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
- Hey this is Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on #AskGaryVee 202.
Who's this and where you from?
And please turn down your
computer or what have you.
- [Cam] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Cam] Hey, this is Cam.
- Cam what's up, baby?
Is his Cam Newton?
- [Cam] I can't
believe I got on.
No, Cam Herald.
I wish it was Cam Newton.
- Cam, where you from?
- [Cam] Oklahoma City.
- Love it, brother.
What can I help you with?
- [Cam] I'm currently working
on a book and I'm interviewing
different entrepreneurs.
What advice would you give to
someone that is trying to get a
hold of influencers
and stuff like that?
- Twitter, Twitter, Twitter,
Twitter, Twitter, Twitter,
Twitter, Twitter, Twitter.
Period. Twitter.
No LinkedIn, no cold
emailing, it's not gonna work.
Go figure out the 500 people you
want to interview, go see what
they're tweeting about.
If you want to interview Cam
Newton go look at Cam Newton's
last 10 tweets try to jump on
the last thing he's talking
about and add value
to the conversation.
Say like "Yeah" or "Disagree" or
"No way" or whatever you
want to go with it.
Create some context so don't ask
for the interview right away,
get in to a little banter
build up a little rapport.
This takes a lot of work, Cam.
This is five, seven, 10 hours a
day every day for a month but
you get, then you go in for the
ask, you get a little context of
those people you ask
them to interview you.
They've been talking to you
about sports or wine or candy or
sailing or surfing or raising
children over the last month now
they got a little context for
Cam on Twitter and then Cam
goes in for the ask one of the
very 80 of those unbelievable
people will say yes so if you
think about 80 people getting
one to say yes and you needing
20 people that's an unbelievable
amount of people that you
need in your ecosystem, right?
You're talking about 1600 people
that you are hitting up which is
going to take you months but
it's putting in the work and
that's how you'll
actually get them.
Got it?
- [Cam] Yeah, appreciate it.
- No worries, brother.
Cam from Oklahoma City.
Let's go to the next one.
- [Phone] Call from--
- Roberto this is
Gary Vaynerchuk from
The #AskGaryVee Show
episode 202.
Roberto Blake always a big
fan, always supported me.
I appreciate you.
I'm glad you're on.
How are you doing?
- [Roberto] I appreciate it man.
I missed you at
Big South yesterday.
I wanted to ask a super
important question about a
business decision
I'm trying to make.
- Let's do it.
- [Roberto] You're the
person that can answer.
- Well, here we are episode 202
of The #AskGaryVee Show coming
through in the clutch.
- [Roberto] Right on.
I am working on a YouTube video
SEO video guide to help some of
my audience who are
struggling with this.
And a lot of my friends are
giving me advice that
I should presell it.
- Okay.
- [Roberto] I feel awkward about
selling something that I haven't
made because I feel awkward
about I want to just deliver on
something, deliver the value.
I feel like why should I sell
it if I haven't made it yet.
What are your thoughts on that?
- I think a lot of people that
watch me and hear me and feel
they know where I'm going to go
with this answer may be
confused by this.
I'm very comfortable with you
preselling it as long as you
feel like you're actually
going to deliver on it.
If you feel like it's actually
going to happen and you're not
taking people's money, I think
pre-selling something and then
not delivering in two ways,
one, not delivering and being a
criminal and stealing people's
money, I don't think you're
going to do that.
And I actually think it's
unacceptable to also even return
the money because you not a god
damn bank and it would've been
much better for them to have
it in your bank account than you.
You just have to hundred percent
make sure that you're going to
deliver and the big
vulnerability because I know you
little bit and I know you'll
deliver on that too the problem
is if you lose energy or
some other amazing opportunity
happens tomorrow, right?
If I email you tomorrow and say
I want to be the new official
cohost of The #AskGaryVee Show
with me but you have to work 10
hours a day when we're not
filming doing X, Y, and Z but
you got to go deliver on this
guide what's going to happen
Roberto is going to bullshit the
guide over the next month or two
'cause your not going to have
time and it's not going to be
the thing you actually thought
it was going to be because you
still finish your word.
The vulnerability of pre-selling
is not delivering to the
capability that you have set in
your mind because you don't know
what's going to happen tomorrow.
Got it?
- [Roberto] Got it.
That is exactly what my concerns
were and you are really good at
figuring that out and yeah you
do know me a little bit so that
was perfect, thanks so much.
- You got it brother.
Thanks watching the show.
- [Roberto] I know
what I need to do now.
- Good brother.
Take care. Alright.
Changing lives
Andy K on episode 202.
See what I did there.
The mouth was the zero.
The mouth, DRock, the mouth.
Actually, I gotta find a good
cadence in-between these calls
while Andy struggles and
makes episodes awkward.
You know what we
could actually do?
We could do the
quick little topics.
Quick hits.
- [India] Quick hits.
The player they got hacked
yesterday right before
he got drafted.
I like how people were confused
and thought that he posted that.
People were like "Yeah, hacked."
I'm like "Yes, hacked."
Yeah hacked being cynical of
somebody getting hacked is when
you say something racist or
inappropriate and then you're
like no no I didn't do that Andy
you can send a call in anytime.
No, I didn't do that my
intern, (phone rings)
oh nice job Andy.
My intern did that.
You don't get hacked when you
post something that cost you
$8 million in 40 minutes. Silly.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
- Hey this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and #AskGaryVee episode 202.
What's your name
and where you from?
- [Calvin] Hey is Calvin Laymen
from the San Diego event
Social Media Marketing World.
- Hey Calvin, how are you?
- [Calvin] Doing well, brother.
My question is my question is
after you have come off this
super successful book number
four launch at what point do you
now set your sights
on book number five?
- That's a great question.
- [Calvin] The next big thing?
- And why are you asking that?
I think that's the more
interesting part of this
question for me.
- [Calvin] I'm just
interested in the minds of
successful people.
How long they bask in their own
success or when they go to the
next thing.
- Cool.
Well, that's a
great question Calvin.
I would tell you and these guys
can say this especially when
they all kind of maybe India
really was in the Vayner world
more than the rest of the gang.
Calvin, I'll tell you it was
crazy what happened inside of my
body when you said
"basked in the success."
I have zero capability of
basking in the success.
I wish the camera was 360
right now because all of my team
except for Andy who is worried
about screwing up the show the
three of the rest them were all
shaking their head because they
know way more than anyone
that's watching right now
that there wasn't even a remote
moment, not a celebration,
we didn't have a dinner.
We didn't get together--
- [Calvin] You
suck at celebration.
- I suck at celebration, man.
I don't have my eyes
set up five right now.
I've got my eyes set on making
VaynerMedia huge, building more
businesses, making smart
investments, helping my
investments build
their businesses.
Getting credibility as a great
businessman while I'm out of
GaryVee mode for a little bit.
Putting out good content,
continuously upping my game in
my distribution of my content,
so there's no book 5 but what
I'll tell you, and Calvin thanks
for calling, what I'll tell you
is that I am always,
always onto the next thing.
As a matter of fact, I would
actually argue this is a slight
vulnerability of mine.
I actually think it would've
probably been smart to have
a dinner with all of us especially
Andy and Alex, you know
all of us really.
To just be like hey
that was a nice launch.
No, we don't have that.
As a matter of fact, let's make
it really intense today is
AJ's last day at VaynerMedia.
I was at a business meeting at a
breakfast spot this morning with
a client, I looked over and AJ
was there was Yudkin and Nate
and Tyler and everybody was
celebrating AJ's,
Tyler get in here real quick.
This is perfect timing.
Why wasn't I invited to AJ's
celebration breakfast
this morning?
- 'Cause you were busy.
- Okay great, get out of here.
What's really interesting
about that there wasn't even
consideration, Tyler,
AJ's former assistant
my current team mate
with India assistant.
There wasn't even consideration.
Think about this: this is my
cofounder little brother's last
day at Vayner
they have a symbol.
This wasn't a one week trip.
This was a simple 90 minute
sendoff breakfast and we didn't
even consider for me
to be a part of it.
Yeah.
It's funny, we don't celebrate
it's a celebration by the way.
It's not like a sad thing.
Now I'll be with AJ tonight
which is great, second day of
the draft but even when we
sold a piece of the business we
forced ourselves a year later we
went to Atlantis in the Bahamas.
We thought we were really
going to celebrate but we just
became degenerates and
gambled for 39 straight hours
only barely even talked about it.
I'm just not good at celebrating
Calvin and by the way I'm not so
sold that's a good idea.
As a matter of fact, I guarantee
that you'll see a blog post from
me whether it's on Medium or
whatever it is of the day
six years from now of
finding celebration.
That's what it's
going to be called.
Finding celebration and it will
talk about me not being happy
that I was so extreme
to the non-celebrating
aspects of business.
I think you should celebrate
the good things in life.
I think it is a miss on the
way that I navigate the world.
It still doesn't come natural to
me it still doesn't, even though
I know this, I'm trying to sell
myself right now but I still
can't get there and I'm
always following this over this.
This says celebrate.
This, that's heart and gut, this
is still not saying celebrate.
And so I can't celebrate.
And honestly if this never says
celebrate and I take last breath
and I think about it for a
second I won't regret it because
I always listen to this.
But this understands that
it's not necessarily
the best move.
And I think it would've been
really nice if we had a nice
dinner and talked war stories,
"Oh remember that time the
"person canceled the
order at the end.
"Ah ha-ha-ah!"
You got one or no?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Where is it?
You need to reset?
- [Staphon] Not reset.
- What are they saying?
- [DRock] They're loving it.
(phone rings)
- They're loving it?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Alright, good.
- [Phone] Call
from unknown caller.
- Hey, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
episode 202.
What's your name and
where you from?
- [Caller] Daniel
from Miami Florida.
How are you?
- I'm great Daniel.
- [Daniel] Happy Passover.
- Thank you, brother, you too.
Thanks for being on the show.
- [Daniel] I'm always
on the show virtually.
I'm not in tech.
I'm actually a songwriter.
I'm releasing an album and I'm
trying to avoid spending money
in ways like hiring
publicists so on and so forth.
- Yes.
- [Daniel] I'm trying to really
ramp up my social side. What I've
been doing is I've invested in
several giveaway items to try
and accumulate a street team
which has worked and I was just
going to find out if you had
any additional ideas because you
will hear about me sooner or
later because this record will
get heard.
- Good for you man.
- [Daniel] I just wanted
to ask your opinion.
- Well, thanks and I'll give
you some opinions and I'll even
throw out there something
that we'll give you.
If you want and you might've
noticed in the last DailyVee we
featured Ron Gilmore Jr.'s music
if you want to reach out to
DRock and talk about some of
your music if you want to have
some of your music featured in
an upcoming DailyVee, I'm not
sure what kind of music it is or
what DRock and Andy's ears are
for that kind of stuff.
- [Daniel] Arabic rap.
- Great. I think you're
really cool.
- [Daniel] I'm kidding.
- Got it.
(laughter)
The craziest is part I was
actually fucking pumped.
I was like yes Arabic rap I know
exactly with the kind intensity.
Anyway, one I'd love to offer
you that because fan of the
show, I'd love to be some
exposure so speak to them and
let's see if that's a fit.
Here's my big plug: Influencers,
influencers, influencers.
I think you took a very
smart tactic of street teams.
I think books and albums when
they do that do quite well.
I think the biggest arbitrage
for attention at the lowest
possible cost right
now are influencers.
If you can get people to
do skits or other things on
Instagram with your music
I think you would crush.
And so I think if you spent two
hours a day just reaching out to
people based on
hashtags on Instagram.
So you go to Instagram you
search hashtags and then you
engage with people that
are putting out stuff around
thematics of either the names of
the songs or the genre of music
or things of that nature I think
you could really have a major
impact by getting some
influencers on board to give you
some awareness and
exposure to your music.
- [Daniel] What about TweetDeck?
Do you think I should continue
doing that 'cause I am engaging
with people through hashtags?
- Yes but I think Instagram
is a better push platform than
Twitter which is why
I'm pushing you that way.
I would also document the
journey of releasing an album.
I would write at least 2 to
4 articles of the journey of
releasing an album on Medium.com
because their editors there pick
some articles and they populate
them to the top and I think
there could be some
real opportunity
for you there as well.
I would also reach out
to places like
HuffPo, Forbes,
Business Insider cold.
Send them an email and say would
you like me to write a piece
original for you on one
musician's point of view on
releasing an
album in 2016, 2017?
All of them are always looking
for content and I believe that's
a very inexpensive quick way for
you to get exposure to a crowd
that might be reading for
business or other things but
everyone loves music and you're
getting awareness, got it?
- [Daniel] Got it totally.
How can I get in touch
with DRock regarding--
- It's DRock@VaynerMedia.com.
- [Daniel] Okay and would it be
okay if I send you a signed copy
of my album and maybe a poster.
- That would be amazing.
Work with DRock he'll
figure everything out and
I wish you well Daniel.
Thanks for
listening and watching.
Thanks brother.
Awesome, good show I
think we got better.
We made a quantum leap
from 200 to 202 but
that's actually up to you.
That's the question of the day
we need feedback as we go into
this new frontier so please
leave your two cents
on the show.
You keep asking questions,
especially if you call,
and I'll keep answering them.
happens we can do fun little
banter and you can do little